The way I always heard the story was that Van Halen had something in the contract that they used when they toured that said that everywhere that they went, in every city, in every dressing room on their tour, there had to be a bowl of M&Ms, and that the brown M&Ms had to be removed. It's kind of a well-known story, I think. And the way that I understood it is that it showed what divas rock stars could be, that any whim that they had would have to be met, no matter how petty. You hate brown M&Ms? Poof! They will cease to exist in your world.
我一直听到的说法是，范·海伦乐队在巡演合同时加入了一项条款，规定他们所到的每一个城市、每一个后台休息室里，都必须有一碗M&M豆，而且必须把棕色的挑出来。我想这算是一个家喻户晓的故事了。我当时理解的是，这体现了摇滚明星有多么傲慢，无论他们的要求多么琐碎，都必须得到满足。你讨厌棕色M&M豆？砰！它们在你的世界里就不复存在了。
And then a couple of years ago, we had this band, They Might Be Giants, on our radio show. And by the way, you're listening to This American Life from WBEZ Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. Anyway, we had this band on the show. And I got to know them a little bit. And I had never talked to a touring rock musician about that story. And I remember John Flansburgh saying to me, no, no, no, no, no. I had the meaning of the story totally wrong.
几年前，有个乐队叫“巨人乐队”（They Might Be Giants）来我们的广播节目做客。顺便说一下，你现在收听的是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。总之，这支乐队上了我们的节目，我和他们熟络了起来。我以前从未和巡演的摇滚乐手聊过那个故事。我记得约翰·弗兰斯伯格对我摇了摇头，说不不不，我完全误解了这个故事的含义。
I think there was only one "no," Ira.
我想当时只有一个“不”字，艾拉。
This is John. I asked him to come and talk about this with me again today, here on the radio. He told me that the music industry name for what we were discussing was the contract rider.
这就是约翰。我今天请他再次来到广播里和我谈谈这件事。他告诉我，音乐行业里我们所讨论的这种条款被称为“演出合约附加条款”。
The thing that the average rock fan doesn't realize is that, in the itinerant life of somebody in a rock band, they're relying on a promoter-- probably a different promoter every day-- to give them everything. And a contract rider is basically the entire show from beginning to end. I mean, you're talking about personnel. You're talking about the PA. So a lot of it's very prosaic stuff. People really focus on the dressing room stuff, but actually most of it is just making sure that there's literally enough electricity in the venue so that the show doesn't end after 10 minutes.
普通的摇滚乐迷不了解的是，对于摇滚乐队的流动生活来说，他们得依赖演出发起人——可能每天都是不同的发起人——来提供一切。合约附加条款基本上涵盖了从头到尾的整场演出。我是说，你要谈及人员配置、音响设备等等。所以很多都是非常琐碎的事情。人们总是盯着休息室里的要求，但实际上，大部分工作只是为了确保场馆里的电力供应充足，不至于让演出在10分钟后就中断。
And this, Flansburgh says, was what was so ingenious about the brown M&Ms. Van Halen had this huge setup with lots of gear, and if the local promoter didn't carefully read the contract rider, stuff could collapse. It could be dangerous. So the brown M&Ms were like the canary in the coal mine. The contract rider said the brown M&Ms were not supposed to be there. If they were there, look out.
弗兰斯伯格说，这就是关于棕色M&M豆的条款如此天才的地方。范·海伦有庞大的演出设备，如果当地发起人没有仔细阅读合约条款，设备可能会倒塌，那会很危险。所以棕色M&M豆就像矿井里的金丝雀。合约规定休息室里不应该有棕色M&M豆。如果出现了，那就小心了。
You know, it was a very clever way to make sure that all the specifics of his contract rider were going to be met, including technical requirements, safety requirements, all the things that David Lee Roth is probably more worried about than his actual M&M needs.
你知道，这是一种非常聪明的方法，用来确保合同中的所有细节——包括技术要求、安全要求等——都能得到落实，而这些都是大卫·李·罗斯可能比他对M&M豆的需求更关心的事情。
Yeah. Actually, in his autobiography, he writes this. I found this on snopes.com. He explains the M&Ms this way. David Lee Roth writes, "Van Halen was the first band to take huge productions into third level markets."
是的。实际上，他在自传里写到了这件事。我在snopes.com上查到了。他这样解释M&M豆的由来。大卫·李·罗斯写道：“范·海伦是第一支将大型制作带入三级市场的乐队。”
Tertiary markets is the word we use in the business.
“三级市场”是我们行业里的专业术语。
Tertiary markets. "We'd pull up with nine 18-wheeler trucks full of gear in places where the standard was three trucks max. And there were many, many technical errors, whether it was the girders couldn't support the weight, or the flooring would sink in, or the doors weren't big enough to move the gear through. The contract rider read like a version of the Chinese Yellow Pages, because there was so much equipment, and so many human beings to make it function. So just as a little test, in article number 126, in the middle of nowhere was, quote, 'There will be no brown M&Ms in the backstage area upon pain of forfeiture of the show with full compensation,' end quote."
三级市场。“我们开着九辆装满设备的大卡车来到这些地方，而当时的标准最多只有三辆。由于技术问题频出，比如钢梁支撑不了重量、地板下陷，或者门太窄导致设备运不进去，合同条款读起来简直像《中文黄页》一样，因为设备太多，操作人员也太多。所以，作为一个小测试，我们在合同第126条中间写道：‘后台区域不得出现棕色M&M豆，否则演出将被取消，且全额赔偿。’”
So, he writes, "When I would walk backstage, if I saw a brown M&M in that bowl, well, line check the entire production, guaranteed you're going to arrive at a technical error. They didn't read the contract. Guaranteed, you'd run into a problem. Sometimes it would threaten to destroy the whole show. Sometimes literally life threatening."
于是他写道：“当我走进后台，如果看到碗里有棕色M&M豆，好吧，那就检查整场演出的技术流程，保证你会发现技术错误。他们根本没读合同。保证你会遇到麻烦。有时这会危及整场演出，甚至在字面上威胁到生命安全。”
Wow.
哇。
Now, when I emailed you to see if you wanted to come on the radio and talk about this, you said, "Oh, that's really a coincidence." Because you just spent your whole day yesterday working on your contract rider?
刚才我发邮件问你愿不愿意来广播谈谈这个，你说：“噢，那真是巧合。”因为你昨天一整天都在忙着处理你的合约附加条款？
Basically, a couple days ago, I was looking at the contract rider, which was 25 pages long. And I realized it was this crazy, Frankenstein document that-- there was some really odd, vestigial stuff. I mean I actually found-- we have all these personnel requirements for loaders, and electricians, and fly riggers, and all these people. There's 30 people that the promoter is going to hire on our behalf, and they have very specific job descriptions. But in only half of them did we require that they be sober.
基本上是这样，几天前我正在查看一份25页长的合约。我意识到这是一个疯狂的、拼凑出来的文件，里面有一些非常奇怪的残留条款。我甚至发现——我们要求发起人聘请装卸工、电工、索具工等，一共30个人，他们有非常具体的职位描述。但其中只有一半人，我们要求必须保持清醒。
Wait, your contract for some of them says specifically they have to be sober?
等等，你们的合同里针对某些人专门要求必须保持清醒？
It was such a hodgepodge that we had, in some cases-- What had happened is that we had had a bunch of loaders that had come in from another show the night before that had ended at 5:00 in the morning. And they came to our show at 7:00 in the morning to, literally, do another show. And they all got drunk in the couple of hours in between.
合同内容非常杂乱。有些情况下，前一天晚上从另一场演出过来的装卸工凌晨5点才结束工作，早上7点就来我们的现场进行下一场演出。在中间的那几个小时里，他们全喝醉了。
So in our contract rider, we said the loaders have to be sober. But unfortunately, the way a contract reads, it looks like you're kind of implying that everybody else can be drunk. And no one had ever thought to cross it out.
所以我们在合约条款里写了装卸工必须清醒。但不幸的是，合同读起来好像是在暗示其他人可以喝醉，而且从来没人想过把它划掉。
Is there an M&Ms clause in your contract?
你们合同里有M&M豆条款吗？
There are some-- It's such a personal thing. It's like asking somebody what's in their medicine chest. There are no M&Ms on our-- We have, like, hummus and tabouli. You would think it was Sarah McLachlan the way our contract rider reads.
这太私人了，就像问别人的药箱里有什么一样。我们合同里没有M&M豆。我们写的是鹰嘴豆泥和塔布勒沙拉。读起来就像是莎拉·麦克拉克伦的合约。
I mean more, is there an M&Ms clause, is there a thing in your contract that you put in there to be sure that people read the contract?
我的意思是，合同里有没有那种专门用来确保对方读过合同的条款？
I think the first line of our contract is the promoter needs to call our tour manager when he gets this rider. That's basically just getting good communication going, rather than bullying and threshold tests, is the way we do it.
我想我们合同的第一行是要求发起人在收到合同后给我们的巡演经理打电话。我们更倾向于建立良好的沟通，而不是搞霸凌或设置门槛测试。
And so if you don't get the call, you know, all right--
如果没收到电话，你就知道……好吧……
Yeah, yeah. And believe it or not, oftentimes they don't call. They've got other things to do.
是的，信不信由你，他们往往不会打电话。他们有别的事要忙。
Well, today on our radio show we have stories of the fine print. We dive into the fine print in places where the fine print really, really matters. Act one of our show, Chana Joffe-Walt explains how the fine print may be the biggest obstacle to getting rid of our acne. Act two, David Rakoff brings us the fine print that could fix what therapy fails to. Act three, Nancy Updike has the story of fine print happening at a place you may never have expected it. Act four, Susan Burton rereads the fine print that changed her childhood. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目主题是“细则”。我们将深入探讨那些真正重要的地方的细则。第一幕，查娜·乔夫-沃尔特解释了为什么细则可能是我们摆脱痤疮的最大障碍。第二幕，大卫·拉科夫带来了那些治疗手段失效时或许能起作用的细则。第三幕，南希·厄普代克带来了细则在某个意想不到的地方发挥作用的故事。第四幕，苏珊·伯顿重读了改变她童年的细则。请继续收听。
Act One. One Pill Two Pill, Red Pill Blue Pill. Let's start today in a place that is swimming in fine print, the insurance business. President Obama said during the health care debates that if we all understood our health care, it would save money.
第一幕。一颗药，两颗药，红药丸，蓝药丸。让我们从一个细则泛滥的地方开始今天的话题——保险业。奥巴马总统在医疗改革辩论期间说过，如果我们都能理解我们的医疗保健，就能节省费用。
If there's a blue pill and a red pill, and the blue pill is half the price of the red pill and works just as well, why not pay half price?
如果有一种蓝药丸和一种红药丸，蓝药丸价格只有红药丸的一半，且效果相同，为什么不选便宜的呢？
And the problem with the fine print is that it makes it hard to tell which pill is the red one and which one is the blue one, as Chana Joffe-Walt explains.
而细则的问题在于，它让人很难分辨哪种是红药丸，哪种是蓝药丸，正如查娜·乔夫-沃尔特所解释的那样。
Ted Serra is in the middle of a war. It's been going on for many years and involves billions of dollars. A lot of us are in this war. And like Ted, we don't even know it. He stumbled onto the battlefield because he's got pimples. Pimples and a card.
泰德·塞拉正处于一场战争之中。这场战争已经持续多年，涉及数十亿美元。我们很多人都身处其中，像泰德一样，甚至毫无察觉。他闯入战场，是因为他有痘痘。痘痘和一张卡片。
It is called the Solodyn Patient Access Card.
那叫“Solodyn患者访问卡”。
What's it look like?
它看起来什么样？
And it looks like a little credit card. It's white and blue.
看起来就像一张小信用卡。白蓝相间的。
The Solodyn Patient Access Card is just the latest weapon in this war. It's an arms race, really, that's been escalating for decades. There have been moves and counter moves before. This war? It is a war over drug co-payments.
Solodyn患者访问卡只是这场战争中的最新武器。这实际上是一场持续了几十年的军备竞赛。以前就有过各种攻防招数。这场战争？是关于药物共同支付（co-pay）的战争。
If you don't, say, run an insurance company, you probably hate co-pays. They are a way to make you pay for your drugs at the pharmacy, even though you're insured. Which seems kind of evil, right? But I tracked down an evil insurance VP, Eileen Wood, who actually was pretty personable. And she said, no, no, no. Co-pays are an insurer's special little way of yelling at us. There are drugs that cost $1000. There are drugs that cost $5. When you're insured, you don't care. You don't even know. So the insurers put a $30 dollar co-pay on one and a $10 co-pay on the other. They're giving you a hint that there is a difference in the drug's total cost.
如果你不是运营保险公司的，你可能很讨厌共同支付。即便你买了保险，在药房买药时还是得自己掏钱。这看起来很邪恶，对吧？但我找到了保险公司的一位副总裁艾琳·伍德，她其实很随和。她说，不不不，共同支付是保险公司提醒我们的一种特殊方式。有些药要1000美元，有些只要5美元。投保时你不在乎，甚至根本不知道。所以保险公司给一种药定30美元的共同支付，另一种定10美元。他们在提示你，药物的总成本是有差异的。
And the consumer doesn't see that. And so we struggle to try to shine the light on that, and get called the bad guy.
消费者看不到这一点。所以我们努力想让大家注意到，结果却成了坏人。
You do get called the bad guy a lot.
你们确实经常被骂成坏人。
Yeah, we do.
是的，没错。
So co-pays were basically a bad guy's way of doing something good for everyone. That's the way Eileen sees it, except for the bad guy thing. Because if insurers could discourage us from buying expensive drugs, it's not just that they would save money. We would save money. They could charge us less in premiums, which we all want.
所以共同支付基本上是坏人试图为大家做点好事的方式，艾琳就是这么看的，除了“坏人”这一点。因为如果保险公司能劝阻我们购买昂贵的药物，不仅他们能省钱，我们也能省钱。他们可以降低保费，这是大家都想要的。
By the 1990s, insurance companies had it down. Co-pays were working really well. The insurers felt like they were winning the war, which was pretty gratifying to people like Eileen Wood. She'd watched for years as drug companies came out with slightly tweaked versions of existing generics and sold them for 10 times the cost.
到20世纪90年代，保险公司已经掌握了诀窍。共同支付效果显著。艾琳·伍德这样的人感到很有成就感。多年来，她眼看着制药公司在现有仿制药基础上稍微修改，就以10倍的价格卖出。
Let's look at Kapidex. Oh, that's this one. I love this one. That's the Minocin, but this company, this is--
看看Kapidex。哦，就是这个。我喜欢这个。那是Minocin，但这家公司……
Eileen works in a tidy office park in Albany, New York, for an insurance company called Capital Districts Physicians Health Plan, CDPHP. And in her file cabinets, she's got plastic, zipped up pouches of her least favorite brand name drugs. She collects them. Minocin, that one she's talking about, there's a generic version that costs about $50 a month. Minocin PAC, which Eileen is now waiving in my face, is a newer brand name drug. It costs $668.
艾琳在奥尔巴尼的一处整洁的办公园区为一家名为CDPHP的保险公司工作。她的文件柜里收集了她最不喜欢的品牌药。Minocin，她刚才提到的那个，有一种仿制药版本，每月只需50美元。而艾琳现在在我面前晃的Minocin PAC是较新的品牌药，售价668美元。
So what's different? It has a couple of little extra items that are not prescription items in there. It has this lovely calming wipe so that when your skin is all red, and you can pat this on. And it's supposed to bring the redness down. It's not a prescription item. Calming serum in a calming mask. It's basically stuff you can buy over the counter. But behind the scenes, it's--
有什么不同呢？它里面加了几样非处方的小东西。比如这个可爱的舒缓湿巾，当你皮肤发红时可以用它擦拭。它宣称能减少红肿，但并不是处方药。还有舒缓精华和舒缓面膜。这基本上是药店随处可买的东西。但在幕后，它……
$668.
668美元。
Yeah.
是的。
And the only difference in this is that it has wipes?
唯一的区别就是有湿巾？
It has these. That's it. That's the only difference. You could probably buy them for $10. So those three products are added to the Minocin PAC, and I guess that must be what costs the extra $600. I'm not sure. It's very slick.
就是这些。仅此而已。那才是唯一的区别。你可能花10美元就能买到。所以那三种产品被加到了Minocin PAC里，我想这就是多收600美元的原因吧。我不确定。非常精明。
Eileen has dozens of stories like this that do seem ridiculous. An acne medication that comes with green tea swabs? Kind of like a prescription for Viagra that comes with a Hustler magazine that costs an extra $500.
艾琳有很多类似的故事，听起来很荒谬。一种配有绿茶棉签的痤疮药？就像买威而钢配一本《好色客》杂志，然后多收500美元。
Now, not all brand names are like this. There are brands that are better than existing generic options, that are the only thing that work for some people. And with co-pays, you can still get the brands. It's just the more expensive choice. You want the green tea swabs, you pay $40 of the $668 for it. If you just want Minocin generic, you pay $10 of the $50 dollars.
当然，并非所有品牌药都这样。有些品牌药确实比现有的仿制药更好，对某些人来说是唯一有效的方案。有了共同支付，你依然可以选择品牌药，只是更贵一些。想要绿茶棉签？那就在668美元里付40美元。如果只需要Minocin仿制药，就在50美元里付10美元。
The co-pay strategy worked so well that in 2003, generics passed the 50% mark, meaning more than 50% of the drugs people went and picked up from pharmacies were generics. It was probably around then that it happened.
共同支付策略非常成功，以至于到2003年，仿制药的份额超过了50%。
The drug companies-- they noticed. People like Sally Beatty at Pfizer. That's the company that makes, among other things, the world's most popular drug, Lipitor. Sally? Not a fan of co-pays.
制药公司注意到了。辉瑞公司的萨莉·比蒂就是其中之一，辉瑞生产世界上最受欢迎的药物——立普妥。萨莉？她不喜欢共同支付。
Now, the issue with that is that we want treatment decisions to be made based on what the physician feels is medically best for the patient, not just the cost to the patient, or what another player may decide is in their interest.
问题在于，我们希望医疗方案是基于医生认为对患者最有利的考虑而制定的，而不是仅仅取决于患者的成本，或者其他参与者认为符合自身利益的事情。
Another player like Eileen Wood and her insurance industry buddies with their co-pays that were hurting the drug companies. Lipitor was facing major competition from generics. In July 2007, sales were down 13%.
比如艾琳·伍德和她的保险业伙伴，他们的共同支付损害了制药公司的利益。立普妥正面临仿制药的巨大竞争。2007年7月，销售额下降了13%。
Now, there is no approved generic for Lipitor. Sally Beatty, from Pfizer, will say this three times in 15 minutes. And what that means is that there is no drug that is chemically identical to Lipitor. What there are are generic drugs in the same class of cholesterol reducing drugs. That's what Lipitor does, reduce cholesterol. And those generics are effective for most people. But there are some people who respond better to Lipitor. And for some of those patients, a $40 co-pay stops them from getting the medication.
目前，立普妥没有获批的仿制药。辉瑞的萨莉·比蒂在15分钟内重复了三次。这意味着没有一种药物在化学成分上与立普妥完全相同。但同类降胆固醇药物中有仿制药。立普妥的作用就是降低胆固醇。对于大多数人来说，仿制药是有效的。但有些人对立普妥反应更好，对于这些人，40美元的共同支付可能让他们无法获得药物。
And so, in 2007, the pharmaceutical industry marshaled its counter-attack. That mysterious card you heard at the beginning of the story, their central weapon. Coupons. A whole bunch of coupons.
于是，2007年，制药业发起了反击。你在故事开头听到的那张神秘卡片，就是他们的核心武器。优惠券。一大堆优惠券。
OK, so I've always had a little bit of acne.
好吧，我一直有点痤疮。
Enter Ted Serra, the paralegal with the card and the pimples-- pimples that, just a few months ago, were in need of drugs.
泰德·塞拉出场了，那个拿着卡片、满脸痘痘的律师助理。就在几个月前，他急需药物。
Yeah, it sort of comes and goes. And generally, when I'm going through more periods of stress either at work or just as a course of life, it sort of gets worse.
是的，它时好时坏。通常当我处于压力较大的时期，无论是在工作中还是生活中，情况就会加重。
Ted walked into the doctor's office. She poked at him with gloved hands and told him, "OK, we're going to put you on a couple topical creams and some antibiotics, a drug called Solodyn." Ted was tentative, but he mentioned he'd been on a generic before, worked pretty well, called Minocycline. And the doc said, "Yeah, that's great. Basically that's the same as Solodyn, but Solodyn is time released. That means, as opposed to Minocycline, which you have to remember to take in the morning and in the evening, you only have to take Solodyn once a day."
泰德走进医生办公室。医生戴着手套检查后说：“好的，我们要给你开几种外用药膏和一些抗生素，一种叫Solodyn的药。”泰德有些犹豫，提到他以前用过仿制药Minocycline，效果很好。医生说：“是的，那很好。基本和Solodyn一样，但Solodyn是缓释的。这意味着，不像Minocycline需要早晚服用，Solodyn每天只需吃一次。”
It didn't really sound that big of a deal to me, but it is, I guess to anyone, slightly easier to take one pill per day instead of two. So I went with it. And I asked in terms of the cost of it just to pay the extra money to take it once a day, if that was going to be a big difference, it wouldn't really be something I'd be interested in. And then she presented this card.
对我来说听起来没多大区别，但确实，对任何人来说，每天吃一次药比吃两次稍微方便点。所以我接受了。我询问了成本，如果只是为了每天吃一次药就要多花钱，那我就没兴趣了。然后她拿出了那张卡。
You remember the card.
你还记得那张卡。
It is called the Solodyn Patient Access Card.
它叫“Solodyn患者访问卡”。
It's actually called Solo-dine, not Solo-din. Who knows where they come up with these names. The point is, this is the moment-- the moment that the drug makers' weapon makes its way into the hands of its oblivious soldier, Ted. Ted was going to get a deal. The doctor explained that this card, it's a coupon. Give it to the pharmacist and it should make your co-pay very affordable, which is exactly what happened. Without the card, Ted's co-pay would have been $154.28. But when Ted got to the pharmacy, he presented his card.
其实发音是Solo-dine，不是Solo-din。谁知道他们怎么想出这些名字的。关键是，就在这一刻，制药商的武器传到了浑然不知的士兵——泰德的手中。泰德将得到优惠。医生解释说这张卡是个优惠券。交给药剂师，你的共同支付就会变得非常便宜，结果也确实如此。没有这张卡，泰德需要支付154.28美元。而当泰德在药房出示卡片时……
They went to ring it up at the register, and when it came up, the price was $10.
结账时，价格变成了10美元。
Ten bucks.
10美元。
That's pretty good for drugs.
那买药的价格还不错。
Yeah, it was great.
是的，太棒了。
Solodyn access achieved.
Solodyn访问成功。
Ted's insurance company was then charged $655 a month for Ted's once a day Solodyn. For reasons too complicated to go into here, they only paid $514. Minocycline, the one that you have to take twice a day, costs $109 a month total. $514. $109.
泰德的保险公司随后每月为泰德每天一次的Solodyn支付了655美元。由于原因太复杂就不展开了，他们实际支付了514美元。而每天需要服用两次的Minocycline，每月总费用是109美元。514美元对比109美元。
Ted never saw those numbers. So you think, OK, well, Ted used the coupon because he didn't really know any better. He thought he was getting a deal. Who wouldn't go for that, right? But the doctor-- what was up with the doctor handing out these cards? Luckily, Dr. Elena Allbritton was generous enough to answer some questions.
泰德从未看到过这些数字。你会想，泰德用了优惠券是因为他不知情，他以为自己占了便宜。谁会拒绝呢，对吧？但医生……医生为什么要发这些卡？幸运的是，埃琳娜·奥布里顿医生慷慨地回答了一些问题。
Do you know the price difference between those two drugs?
你知道这两种药物的价格差异吗？
I don't.
不知道。
Like Ted and the majority of Americans, Dr. Allbritton has no idea what drugs actually cost, not because she's lazy, but because these numbers are really hard to find out. The insurance companies, they all individually negotiate with drug companies, and they each pay a slightly different amount. So no, Dr. Allbritton is not thinking about prices when prescribing. She's thinking, what is the best thing available for this patient? Solodyn is better. It's easier to take a pill once a day, instead of twice. It's easier for Dr. Allbritton to get the dosage just right. And Dr. Allbritton wants her patients to have the best.
像泰德和大多数美国人一样，奥布里顿医生完全不知道药品的真实成本，不是因为她懒，而是因为这些数字很难查到。保险公司各自与制药公司谈判，支付的金额略有不同。所以，奥布里顿医生开处方时并不考虑价格。她考虑的是，对这个病人来说最好的药是什么？Solodyn更好。每天吃一次药比两次容易，医生也能更容易掌握剂量。奥布里顿医生希望病人得到最好的照顾。
I think if I can get a discount for most patients, I think it's great, because the cost of medications can be very high. It's like a free gift to give.
如果能为大多数病人争取到折扣，我认为太棒了，因为医药费可能非常高昂。这就像一份免费的礼物。
Dr. Allbritton just wants it to be easy for patients to access the drugs she thinks they need. Truthfully, she doesn't really want to keep track of all the prices. That's not her job.
奥布里顿医生只是想让病人更轻松地获取所需的药物。说实话，她并不想跟踪所有的价格。那不是她的工作。
I just don't think that it's realistic to have that responsibility fall on the physician. I mean, then are you going to start saying, "Well, should I really do this biopsy? Because I'm not really sure that it's really that significant of a difference in that mole. And it might cost you $1200 in the end if this doesn't get covered." I mean, you don't want to start thinking about price tags with everything.
我认为让医生承担这个责任是不现实的。这意味着我要开始考虑：“我是不是该做这个活检？因为我不确定痣的区别是否真的那么大，而万一最终保险不覆盖，你可能要花1200美元。”你不会想在所有事情上都考虑价格标签。
Actually, when people talk about how to reform health care in our country, this is one of the things they talk about changing. That doctors should know the prices of things, and at least play some role in deciding whether a time release version of a pill is worth $400 more to everyone.
事实上，当人们讨论如何改革医疗保健时，这正是他们讨论的议题之一。医生应该了解药品的价格，至少在决定缓释版药物是否值得多花400美元时发挥一定作用。
The maker of Solodyn is Medicis. They wouldn't talk to me. By the way, in the months since Ted started taking Solodyn, a generic version has come out. And the war has escalated. Another tactical maneuver-- drug makers used to just give cards to doctors. Now they distribute them to patients too. They're in women's magazines. They're online. They're at the drug store counter. They're everywhere, except in Massachusetts where they're illegal. And we pick them up. We see a deal. Like Ted, we like deals. And Eileen Wood, at the insurance company, she gets that.
Solodyn的生产商是Medicis。他们不愿接受采访。顺便说一下，泰德开始服用Solodyn后的几个月，一种仿制药上市了。战争升级了。另一个战术动作——制药商过去只给医生卡片，现在也直接发给病人。在女性杂志里，在网上，在药店柜台上，到处都是。除了在马萨诸塞州，那里违法。我们看到了，觉得是划算的交易。像泰德一样，我们喜欢折扣。而保险公司的艾琳·伍德理解这一点。
I can't argue with that argument, except to say there is a consequence for that.
我无法反驳这种论点，除非说明这会有后果。
Because what will you have to do if everybody gets the more expensive drug?
因为如果每个人都购买昂贵的药物，你必须做什么？
We'd have to raise premiums. I mean, I think there's no question about that. It would have an impact on him, and everybody that sits next to him.
我们必须提高保费。我认为这毫无疑问。这会影响泰德，以及坐在他身边的每个人。
At work.
在工作中。
At work, and their families, and so forth. Yes.
工作中，还有他们的家人等等。是的。
I don't want to pay more in premiums next year, and I don't want everyone around me to have to either.
我不想明年交更多保费，也不想周围的人这样做。
Do you think your co-workers are going to hear this and go, "Well, thanks a lot, Ted. You and your fancy acne medicine."
你觉得你的同事听到这些会说：“泰德，真得谢谢你了。你和你那高档的痤疮药。”
Probably. But there I was sitting in dermatologist's office, and I have no idea. Again, I had never heard of this medicine. I had no idea how much it cost. I know it's brand name. But I certainly never would've dreamed that it would have cost $655 sticker price.
可能会。但我当时坐在皮肤科医生办公室里，我一无所知。再说一次，我从未听说过这种药。我不知道它要多少钱。我知道它是品牌药，但我绝对不敢想象它要655美元。
Looking at this war laid out like this, it's a view of a health care system that is comprised of enormous insurance companies throwing their weight around, just as enormous drug companies striking back, and then all these idiots in the middle-- us. You, me, and our doctors. Pesky interlopers who don't even know the price of the pills we're buying.
纵观这场战争，这是一个医疗系统的缩影，由庞大的保险公司施加影响，巨型制药公司反击，而我们这些中间的白痴——你、我和我们的医生——不过是不知道药价的无辜路人。
President Obama wants us to choose the blue pill and not the red pill, because the blue is just as effective but half the price. But with these cards, which one is the blue one? We have no idea.
奥巴马总统希望我们选蓝药丸而不是红药丸，因为蓝药丸效果相同但价格减半。但有了这些卡片，哪一个是蓝药丸？我们根本不知道。
Chana Joffe-Walt is a member of the Planet Money team. That story first aired in 2009. Since then, the Solodyn Patient Access Card has been discontinued. It's now part of a different program, the Medicis MediSAVE Program, which is more of a package deal that allows you to get a few other drugs cheaper as well.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特是“Planet Money”团队的一员。那个故事最初在2009年播出。从那时起，Solodyn患者访问卡已经停用。它现在成为了一个名为“Medicis MediSAVE”项目的一部分，这更像是一个组合优惠，让你能以更低的价格买到其他几种药。
We've arrived at act two of our show. Act Two, Occupancy May Be Revoked Without Notice. This next bit of fine print was brought to us by David Rakoff.
我们进入节目的第二幕。“入住权可随时撤销，恕不另行通知”。这段细则由大卫·拉科夫带给我们。
The following shall constitute the binding agreement between Mr. Gregory Stolzenberg of Yonkers, New York, hereafter known as Owner, and his mother, Mrs. Barbara Stolzenberg, of Tenafly, New Jersey, hereafter known as Mother, in regards to the third floor bedroom of number 41 Old Alewives Lane, Yonkers, New York.
以下内容构成纽约州扬克斯市的格雷戈里·斯托尔岑伯格先生（以下简称“业主”）与他新泽西州特纳弗莱市的母亲芭芭拉·斯托尔岑伯格夫人（以下简称“母亲”）之间关于纽约州扬克斯市老阿利维斯巷41号三楼卧室的约束性协议。
One. Upon completion of chemotherapy and surgery at the Memorial Sloan-Kettering Cancer Center, Mother shall take occupancy for an as yet undetermined period of time, hereafter known as convalescent period, not to exceed four weeks in duration.
一、在纪念斯隆-凯特琳癌症中心完成化疗和手术后，母亲应入住该房间，入住期限（以下简称“康复期”）尚未确定，但不得超过四周。
Two. A front door key will be left underneath the stone frog near the rhododendron. Mother agrees to return said key to its hiding place, for once.
二、前门钥匙将留在杜鹃花附近的石蛙下方。母亲同意这次把钥匙放回原处。
Three. Mother acknowledges herewith that she is aware that, as a converted attic, the third floor and its bedroom are accessible by a retractable ladder.
三、母亲在此承认，她知道三楼卧室是阁楼改建的，必须通过伸缩梯进入。
Subparagraph one. Mother hereby waives any and all recourse to the Americans with Disabilities Act and to any liability on Owner's part in the event of any injury.
小项一：母亲特此放弃《美国残疾人法案》赋予的所有诉诸权利，并免除业主在发生任何伤害时承担的任何责任。
Subparagraph two. Included in Mother's accommodation, she shall be given 24-hour access to the bathroom on the second floor.
小项二：在母亲入住期间，业主将为其提供二楼卫生间的24小时使用权。
Four. Per Mother's previous request, she shall occupy the lower bunk of the third floor bedroom, while Owner's eight-year-old son, Robby Stozenberg, shall occupy the top bunk.
四、应母亲之前的要求，她将入住三楼卧室的下铺，业主八岁的儿子罗比·斯托尔岑伯格入住上铺。
Five. Mother may take breakfast and supper with the family-- please see attached appendix detailing the meal plan-- and agrees that upon finishing eating, she will, quote, "make herself scarce." As has been previously and frequently discussed, quote, "sitting quietly with a magazine and not saying a word, even if you begged me to say something," unquote, differs wholly in spirit, letter, and intention from making oneself scarce. Mother further agrees not to do, quote, "that thing with the chewing and the breathing."
五、母亲可以和家人共进早餐和晚餐——请参阅附录中详细的膳食计划——并同意在用餐结束后， quote “保持低调”。如前所述，“静静地坐着看杂志，即使我求你说话也不发一言”，在精神、文字和意图上与“保持低调”完全不同。母亲进一步同意不要做“那个咀嚼和呼吸的声音”。
Subparagraph one. Further to the matter of, quote, "making oneself scarce," unquote-- and it is herein that this subparagraph not be construed as belaboring a matter to the point of obsession-- but Mother further concedes herein that both Owner and his wife have been medically assessed to be of excellent to above average hearing. And as such, any and all comments, even though spoken at a whisper, are perfectly audible. Further, Owner's wife, as a Mexican-born Catholic, and therefore, not possessed of a formal Yiddish education, is well aware that the word "kurveh" has entered common English usage to mean "whore." And the use of said word, even when muttered, is heard and emphatically not appreciated.
小项一：关于“保持低调”——此处并非为了强迫他人达到某种偏执程度——但母亲在此进一步承认，业主及其妻子的听力都被医学评估为优良至中上水平。因此，任何评论，哪怕是耳语，都能被听得一清二楚。此外，业主的妻子作为墨西哥裔天主教徒，不懂意第绪语，但她很清楚“kurveh”进入日常英语中是指“妓女”。即使是在咕哝时使用该词，我们也能听到，并明确表示极其反感。
Six. Mother may make daily use of the public rooms on the main floor, such as the living room, from 11:00 AM to 3:00 PM, or until Robby Stolzenberg returns home from school, whichever happens sooner, at which time, Mother must relinquish the television remote and, quote, "make herself scarce," unquote. See paragraph five.
六、母亲可在每天上午11点至下午3点，或者罗比·斯托尔岑伯格放学回家前（以较早者为准）使用主楼的公共区域，如客厅。届时，母亲必须交出电视遥控器，并 quote “保持低调”。见第五条。
Mother may receive visitors, no more than two a day, although under no circumstances may Mother receiver her daughter, the omniscient and perfect-- it is acknowledged that both adjectives are being employed ironically-- Mrs. Marla Stolzenberg-Burns of Ho-Ho-Kus, New Jersey, for reasons that have been previously and frequently discussed. If Mrs. Stolzenberg-Burns' eagerness to see her mother is deemed as so overwhelming, then perhaps the entire location of the convalescent period can be reassessed. Just say the word. Go on. Say it. Say it. Say it.
母亲可以接待访客，每天不超过两人，但在任何情况下，母亲不得接待她那位全知全能的完美女儿——承认这两个形容词带有讽刺意味——新泽西州霍霍库斯的玛拉·斯托尔岑伯格-伯恩斯夫人，原因如前所述。如果玛拉·斯托尔岑伯格-伯恩斯夫人急于见到母亲，那么整个康复地点可能需要重新考虑。只要说一声。说吧。说出来。说出来。说出来。
Subparagraph one. Mention is made hereby that, in the matter of the husband of the omniscient and perfect Mrs. Marla Stolzenberg-Burns-- the Owner's brother-in-law, Dr. Howard Burns of Ho-Ho-Kus, New Jersey-- Mother further agrees that there is a material difference between a dermatologist and God Almighty. And that there are, indeed, many things that the former does not know, regardless of how much he pulls down annually.
小项一：特此提及，关于全知全能的完美玛拉·斯托尔岑伯格-伯恩斯夫人的丈夫——业主的姐夫，新泽西州霍霍库斯的霍华德·伯恩斯博士——母亲进一步同意，皮肤科医生和上帝之间存在本质区别。尽管他年薪很高，但前者确实有很多事情不知道。
Seven. All efforts have been made herein to draft an impartial agreement with malice and favor towards none. This document is to serve as a mutual protection to both parties, and the full execution of which, it is hoped, will avert any future difficulties that might in any way resemble events of Thanksgiving 2005, 2006, 2007, or August 2008, at the beach.
七、本文已尽一切努力起草一份对双方皆公正的协议，不偏不倚。本文件旨在作为双方的共同保护，并希望其全面执行能避免未来出现任何类似于2005、2006、2007年感恩节，或2008年8月海滩活动那样的困难。
David Rakoff is the author of several books, including his most recent, Half Empty .
大卫·拉科夫是多本书的作者，包括他最新的著作《半空》。
Coming up, what's fine print in Farsi? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，波斯语里的细则怎么说？一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目将继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Fine Print. You know, usually most of us try to just skip the fine print. We don't read the rental car agreements, or the software license end-user agreements. We just click, I agree. Today on our show, we have stories where the fine print has real consequences. We have arrived at act three of our show.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，讲述不同的故事。今天的主题是“细则”。你知道，通常我们大部分人都尽量跳过细则。我们不读租车协议，也不读软件许可协议。只是点击“我同意”。今天在节目中，我们有关于细则带来现实后果的故事。我们已到达节目的第三幕。
Act Three. Side Effects May Include.
第三幕。副作用可能包括。
A confession is not supposed to have any fine print. It's supposed to state, "This is what happened. This is what I did," all very straightforward. But of course all kinds of confessions come with asterisks included. This story that you're about to hear is about a confession given in Iran. And just to review, two years ago, if you remember, there were massive protests in Iran following a disputed election that returned Mahmoud Ahmadinejad to power for a second term. And many Iranians believed that the election was rigged and that a more moderate politician had actually won.
忏悔不应该有细则。它应该声明：“这就是发生的事。这是我做的，”非常直接。但当然，所有的忏悔都带着星号。你即将听到的故事是关于伊朗的一份忏悔。回顾一下，如果你还记得的话，两年前在伊朗发生了一场大规模抗议，起因是有争议的选举让艾哈迈迪内贾德赢得了第二个任期。许多伊朗人认为选举被操纵了，而一位更温和的政治家其实赢了。
This story actually starts before all that, before Ahmadinejad, in 2004, a time when moderate reformists still were leading the government in Iran, but not for very long. Nancy Updike tells what happened.
这个故事实际上从那之前就开始了，在艾哈迈迪内贾德之前，在2004年，当时温和派还在伊朗政府掌权，但时间不长。南希·厄普代克讲述了发生了什么。
At 30 years old, Omid Memarian, a journalist in Iran, went where he wanted, talked to whomever he felt like talking to-- reformists, hardliners, foreigners, the vice president of the World Bank. Why not? Political debate in Iran was robust. Omid's view was, he lived in a country that had problems, and he was a critic of those problems. But it also had a constitution, elections, some independent newspapers. Iran wasn't North Korea. It wasn't Myanmar.
30岁的奥米德·梅马里安是伊朗的一名记者，他想去哪就去哪，想和谁谈就和谁谈——改革派、强硬派、外国人、世界银行副行长。为什么不呢？伊朗的政治辩论非常激烈。奥米德认为他生活在一个有问题的国家，他也是问题的批评者。但它也有宪法、选举、一些独立报纸。伊朗不是北韩。也不是缅甸。
In October of 2004, Omid was arrested at his office by government men in plain clothes. Didn't have badges. Did have guns. And within a few hours, Omid was sitting in an interrogation room at a prison whose name and location he didn't know. After a while, a man walked in.
2004年10月，奥米德在办公室被穿着便服的政府人员逮捕。没有证件。有枪。几个小时内，奥米德坐在一个他不知道名字和位置的监狱审讯室里。过了一会儿，一个男人走了进来。
Like 55 years old, with a very short beard, and kind of calm. And I felt that this guy might be a nice guy. But when I said hi to this guy, then he just started beating me. And I was sitting next to the wall on a chair. And the guy took my head and was hitting my head to the wall. And he was doing that, and at one point I remember the guy was asking me if I ever traveled to the US.
大约55岁，胡子很短，看起来很冷静。我以为这人可能是个好人。但当我向他问好时，他开始打我。我坐在墙边的椅子上。那个人揪着我的头往墙上撞。他边撞边问我有没有去过美国。
In 2004, I was invited to come here to the US and give a speech. So I got my visa. I went to Frankfurt airport, and then somebody called my name. So they told me that my name was on the No-Fly List. At least, I think Osama bin Laden probably is on the top. So I took the first flight, and I went back home.
2004年，我被邀请来美国发表演讲。所以我拿到了签证。我去了法兰克福机场，有人叫了我的名字。他们告诉我我的名字在禁飞名单上。至少，我认为本·拉登可能排在第一位。所以我买了第一班飞机，回了家。
So the interrogator was asking me what happened in Washington, DC. And I said, "Hi. I didn't go there. I was on the No-Fly List, probably you guys are there. We are all on that list." And the guy said, "No. We have tapes of those meetings that you had in Washington, DC. We have all the documents." And I said, "Dude, I have not been there. All right? You should look at my passport. It doesn't show anything. There is no stamp on my passport." At that moment, I learned that they really, in many cases, they bluff. They just bluff.
所以审讯者问我在华盛顿特区发生了什么。我说：“你好。我没去那儿。我在禁飞名单上，可能你们也在上面。我们都在那名单上。”那个人说：“不。我们有你在华盛顿开会的录音。我们有所有文件。”我说：“伙计，我根本没去过那儿。好吗？你应该看看我的护照。上面什么都没有。护照上没有印章。”那一刻，我了解到在很多情况下，他们真的在虚张声势。他们只是在虚张声势。
And once you figured out that part of what they were doing was bluffing, was that a relief? Or was that more terrifying? I mean, did that make you feel like, "I have no idea what to do?"
当你发现他们是在虚张声势时，是感到解脱？还是更恐惧？你是觉得：“我不知道该怎么办？”
When they bluffed at the beginning, I thought, "Oh, there is nothing here." But the thing was, when you have to talk about something that never happened, it was much harder than to talk about something that happened. Because when nothing was there, it was really hard to imagine that kind of incident.
起初他们虚张声势时，我心想：“哦，这里什么都没有。”但问题是，当你必须谈论一件从未发生过的事情时，比谈论一件发生过的事情难多了。因为当什么都没有时，真的很难想象那种场景。
I mean, this guy was beating me. And at one point I was on the floor. He was hitting my stomach with his leg. At one point, in that case, I threw up. I just couldn't accept that, because I never went to the US.
我的意思是，那家伙在打我。有一刻我倒在地板上。他用腿踢我的胃。有一刻，我吐了。我无法接受，因为我从没去过美国。
Forced confessions are not a new phenomenon, more like eternal. And Omid got the standard treatment, beatings and solitary. But every government that forces confessions has its own variation on the process, its own way of building up its library of confessions.
强迫忏悔不是什么新现象，更像是永恒的。奥米德受到了标准对待，殴打和单独监禁。但每个强制忏悔的政府都有其独特的过程，有其建立忏悔库的方式。
They gave me a kind of notebook and a pen, and asked me to start writing everything you have done over the past seven years. So I thought, "That's fine. I can write everything. I don't have any secret, and there's nothing to be worried about."
他们给了我一本笔记本和一支笔，让我开始写过去七年里做过的所有事。所以我想：“那很好。我可以把一切都写下来。我没有秘密，没什么可担心的。”
So he was there. I was sitting on a chair, and I started writing. There was a table there too. And every five minutes, he asked me to see my writing. Every five minutes. And then when he saw what I was writing, he screamed at me and said, "This is not what I want. This not what I want from you. You should tell me the truth." And I said, "This is the truth." And he said, "No. You're hiding truth. Tell me what happened behind the doors."
他就在那儿。我坐在椅子上开始写。桌上也有东西。每隔五分钟，他就让我给他看我的写作。每五分钟。当我写完给他看时，他对我大喊：“这不是我要的。这不是我要你写的。你应该告诉我真相。”我说：“这就是真相。”他说：“不。你在隐瞒真相。告诉我门后发生了什么。”
I had no idea what he wanted me to write for them. I had no idea, because I said in many cases, that this is exactly what happened. This is exactly the people I met. Actually, I wrote a biography of myself for them. It was a very honest biography. I even talked about things I never talked to my mom, or dad, or my friends.
我不知道他想让我给他们写什么。我不知道，因为我说了，在很多情况下，这就是真实发生的。这就是我见过的人。实际上，我为他们写了一份自传。那是一份非常诚实的自传。我甚至谈到了从未告诉过妈妈、爸爸或朋友的事情。
They asked about my girlfriends. In Iran, you cannot have a girlfriend when you are not married. And the guy asked me to confess about my sexual relationship. "Tell me how you started. Did you use condom? Did you use porn? Did you watch porn?" I start crying. I begged him. I begged him, please, do not ask that. Please do not ask that. I cannot do that. And I was like, oh my God, where are you going from here? And he forced me to write that.
他们问起我的女朋友。在伊朗，没结婚不能有女朋友。那个人让我坦白性关系。“告诉我你是怎么开始的。你用避孕套吗？你用色情作品吗？你看色情作品吗？”我开始哭。我求他。求你，别问那个。别问那个。我做不到。我心想，天哪，你要把我带到哪儿去？他强迫我写了下来。
They told me all the time, you know, you're going to stay here for six months, a year, two years. You're not going to go home. Forget it. And I was so devastated. I felt so hopeless. And I said, "God, please help me. These people are doing this with me with your name, reading Koran, praying five times a day." The guy was beating me, and sometimes stopped beating me to pray on time.
他们一直跟我说，你要在这里待六个月、一年、两年。你回不了家。忘掉吧。我非常绝望。我感到无比无助。我说：“上帝，请帮帮我。这些人用你的名义在对我做这种事，读着《古兰经》，每天祈祷五次。”那个人在打我，有时甚至停下来去准时祈祷。
And at one point in the thing, I remember once I watched a movie-- its name is Irreversible . I think it was in my mind all the time. There's a point in everybody's life that your life separates to before that event, and after that. So for me, I knew that there's a point that I cannot take more pressure. I knew people who stayed for a long time in prison, and they'd never be able to come back to their normal life. They never become normal persons.
有一刻，我记得曾看过一部电影——叫《不可撤销》。我想我脑子里一直闪过那个画面。每个人的生命中都有一个点，你的生活分为那个事件之前，和之后。所以对我来说，我知道有一个点，我无法再承受更多压力了。我认识那些在监狱里待了很长时间的人，他们永远无法回到正常生活。他们再也无法成为正常人。
They never recovered.
他们永远没有恢复过来。
They never recovered. And I knew those people. I talked to those people. I didn't want to be those people at the age of 30. And at one point, when the pressure was so high, I thought I was entering to the irreversible part.
永远没有。我认识这些人。我和他们交谈过。我不想在30岁时变成那样。当压力过大时，我想我正在进入那个不可撤销的部分。
In the third week, he gave in.
在第三周，他妥协了。
I said, "OK. What do you want me to write for you?" And they said, "So, these are the names. These are the topics." I drafted my story. It was the only unpaid story I have written in my life. I'm always paid. But anyways--
我说：“好吧。你想让我为你写什么？”他们说：“那么，这些是名字。这些是主题。”我起草了我的故事。那是我生命中唯一一篇没收钱写的文章。我总是拿钱写文章。但不管怎样……
The only unpaid story you've ever written in your life was your false confession?
这是你生命中唯一一篇没收钱写的文章，就是你的虚假忏悔？
Yes. I drafted my story. I gave it to my interrogator. And then, he was like my editor. He changed some of the names, and he just changed the order. And then, he gave me a few pages' analysis. And I had to include those approaches, those lines, in my confessions.
是的。我起草了我的故事。交给了审讯者。然后，他就像我的编辑。他改了一些名字，改变了顺序。然后，他给了我几页分析。我必须把那些思路、那些台词加进我的忏悔里。
He's literally-- your interrogator is literally writing on your draft. He's making notes in the margins, and crossing things out, and adding things like an editor?
他实际上……你的审讯者实际上是在你的草稿上写作。他在页边做笔记，划掉东西，添加内容，就像编辑一样？
Exactly like that. He gave me directions. For example, I said I wrote for this newspaper or that newspaper. I went to these countries. I met these people. So in their version was, with the suggestion of that politician, I went to this country. And I was a part of a plan. It was a big plan. And I had to say that I intentionally, and sometimes unintentionally, have cooperated with them through my writings, through my blog, through my travels, through my talks, and that kind of things.
正是这样。他给我指示。例如，我说我为这份报纸或那份报纸写过稿。我去过这些国家。我见过这些人。所以他们的版本是，在某位政治家的建议下，我去了这个国家。我是计划的一部分。这是一个大计划。我必须说我有意，有时是无意地通过我的写作、博客、旅行、交谈等方式与他们合作。
Were there specific words he wanted you to use?
有什么具体的词他想让你用吗？
Definitely I had to use Velvet Revolution.
绝对要用“天鹅绒革命”。
And how do you say Velvet Revolution in Farsi?
波斯语里怎么说天鹅绒革命？
[SPEAKING IN FARSI]
（波斯语发言）
And he wanted you to put those exact words in?
他要求你必须用那确切的词？
Exact words.
确切的词。
Confessions in Iran are sometimes broadcast on TV. They show up in the evenings on the state-run news programs. Transcripts of confessions are also posted on government websites. And watching, reading, and hearing about one Iranian confession after another, it's impossible not to notice a distinct and unchanging editorial vision at work here. Because the fact is, people in Iran who have never met each other have nevertheless been confessing to a lot of the same things in a lot of the same ways for at least 10 years.
伊朗的忏悔有时会在电视上播出。它们出现在晚上的国家新闻节目中。忏悔的笔录也会被张贴在政府网站上。观看、阅读和听到一个又一个伊朗人的忏悔，不可能不注意到这里有一个独特且不变的编辑视角。事实是，从未见过面的伊朗人，至少在过去10年里，以同样的方式坦白了同样的事情。
WOMAN [SPEAKING IN FARSI]
（女性波斯语发言）
In these video clips, one ordinary Iranian after another is confessing to having been manipulated by the BBC and Voice of America to cause mayhem or undermine the regime.
在这些视频剪辑中，一个接一个普通的伊朗人承认受到英国广播公司（BBC）和美国之音（VOA）的操纵，从而引发混乱或破坏政权。
And here's another confession. There's no tape, but we've got a transcript. It's a TV confession from a documentary filmmaker and reporter for Newsweek in Iran. Maziar Bahari was arrested after the election. His confession is a classic of the genre. It's so crammed with buzz phrases and bullet points, that in some parts it gets hard to understand.
这里还有一份忏悔。没有录像，但我们有笔录。这是一份电视忏悔，来自伊朗的一名纪录片导演和《新闻周刊》记者。马齐亚尔·巴哈里在选举后被捕。他的忏悔是该体裁的经典。它充斥着时髦的口号和要点，以至于有些部分很难理解。
It says, quote, "I, as a journalist and as part of the huge capitalist machinery of the West, sometimes blindly and sometimes intentionally positioned myself on the side that was suggesting that a Color Revolution was under way. According to the models of Color and Velvet Revolutions, we can consider the incidents in recent weeks as classic, but defeated, examples of a Color Revolution, because it has the same properties as a Color Revolution."
它写道：“我，作为一名记者，作为西方庞大资本主义机器的一部分，有时盲目，有时有意地将自己定位在暗示一场‘颜色革命’正在进行的一方。根据颜色革命和天鹅绒革命的模式，我们可以将最近几周发生的事件视为颜色革命的经典但已失败的例子，因为它具有与颜色革命相同的特征。”
When Omid, heard that a transcript of this guy Maziar's confession was going to be released, he bet a friend, who'd also been imprisoned in Iran, that they could guess what would show up in Maziar's confession. So they wrote down their guesses. When they read the confession, they were stunned at how right they were.
当奥米德听说那个马齐亚尔的忏悔记录即将公布时，他和一位也曾在伊朗入狱的朋友打赌，猜猜马齐亚尔的忏悔里会出现什么内容。他们写下了猜测。当他们阅读忏悔时，对自己的准确性感到震惊。
Because what Maziar Bahari said was not Maziar's language. Everybody who knows Maziar, everybody who knows the other guy, Mahdavi-- I mean [? Jose ?] Mahdavi-- we used to work at the same newspaper-- nice guy. They didn't talk with the language. It was interrogator's language. It's the security force's language. What he said was a kind of analysis. I read that analysis inside the prison. It was the same. The narrative was very clear. The foreigners are influencing society. They want to change the society. Velvet Revolution.
因为马齐亚尔·巴哈里所说的不是马齐亚尔自己的语言。每个认识马齐亚尔的人，每个认识那个人马赫达维的人——我们曾在同一家报纸工作——好人。他们不说这种话。这是审讯者的语言。这是安全部队的语言。他所说的是一种分析。我在监狱里读过那种分析。是一样的。叙事非常清楚。外国人正在影响社会。他们想改变社会。天鹅绒革命。
Another recurring part of the narrative is the inclusion of the names of foreign people and institutions whenever possible, hopefully famous ones. The BBC, CNN, Newsweek, The New York Times , George Soros, President Clinton, UCLA, Princeton, all have appeared in various confessions. I talked to one former student activist arrested in 2000, Ali Afshari, who confessed to intentionally criticizing the Supreme Leader, and unintentionally trying to overthrow the regime.
叙事中另一个重复的部分是尽可能多地包含外国人物和机构的名字，希望是著名的。BBC、CNN、《新闻周刊》、《纽约时报》、乔治·索罗斯、克林顿总统、加州大学、普林斯顿大学，都出现在了各种忏悔中。我和一位2000年被捕的前学生活动家阿里·阿夫沙里交谈过，他承认有意批评最高领袖，并试图推翻政权。
Ali's interrogator tried to get him to write into his confession that former CIA Director George Tenet had personally guided the overthrowing plan. Of course, the CIA did famously orchestrate an overthrow in Iran in 1953, a truth that, for many Iranians, no doubt makes anything seem possible. But for Ali, the idea that he, as a student activist, had been a lackey for George Tenet was absurd and insulting. It was as though his confession was a historical novel, and his editor kept trying to get them to beef up the realness by sprinkling in actual historical figures.
阿里的审讯者试图让他写进忏悔，说前中情局局长乔治·特内特亲自指导了颠覆计划。当然，中情局曾于1953年在伊朗策划了一次政变，这对许多伊朗人来说，毫无疑问让一切看起来都有可能。但对于阿里来说，作为一个学生活动家竟然是乔治·特内特的走狗，这太荒谬和侮辱人了。仿佛他的忏悔是一部历史小说，而他的编辑一直想通过撒入真实的历史人物来增加真实感。
By now, Iranian political confessions have become so repetitive and recognizable that one of Iran's most famous political satirists, Ebrahim Nabavi, recently posted a fake one on YouTube.
到现在，伊朗的政治忏悔已经变得如此重复和可识别，伊朗最著名的政治讽刺作家易卜拉欣·纳巴维最近在YouTube上发布了一份虚假的忏悔。
[SPEAKING IN FARSI]
（波斯语发言）
The comedian is dressed in prison stripes, and identifies himself as Mohammed-Ali Abtahi, the former vice president of Iran. If that seems like part of the joke, it isn't. Abtahi is one of the hundreds of people who have been in prison since the election. In the spoof, the comedian looks sheepishly at the camera and says, "I confess that when I traveled to holy Mecca, I met with one of the agents from the frightening CIA. He called me and offered me to do a Velvet Revolution."
喜剧演员穿着囚服，自称是穆罕默德-阿里·阿布塔希，伊朗前副总统。如果这看起来像笑话的一部分，其实不是。阿布塔希是选举后被关进监狱的数百人之一。在模仿中，喜剧演员害羞地看着镜头说：“我承认，当我前往圣城麦卡时，我遇到了可怕的中情局特工之一。他打电话给我，提议让我搞一场天鹅绒革命。”
There are obvious edits in the satire video. And over the course of the story, the comedian's face gets covered in more and more Band-Aids. As he continues, he admits that he eventually agreed to do the Velvet Revolution as long as he could do it his way. "I imported a few bolts of green velvet fabrics from Israel and England. During this time, in addition to millions of dollars of funding that was handed to me by Christiane Amanpour, I also started the green velvet fabric business."
讽刺视频中有明显的剪辑。随着故事的进行，喜剧演员的脸上贴满了创可贴。他继续承认，只要能按自己的方式做，他最终同意进行天鹅绒革命。“我从以色列和英国进口了几匹绿色天鹅绒布料。在此期间，除了克里斯蒂安·阿曼普尔给我的数百万美元资金外，我还开始了绿色天鹅绒布料生意。”
Later in the story, he suggests to one of his co-conspirators that they should change the revolution to focus on a cheaper fabric than velvet. The comedian, by the way, was himself forced to confess years ago. He no longer lives in Iran.
在故事的后面，他向同谋者建议，他们应该把革命重点放在比天鹅绒更便宜的布料上。顺便说一下，这位喜剧演员本人多年前也被迫忏悔过。他现在不再居住在伊朗。
These confessions, for all their heavy-handedness, have been crushingly effective. They've ended careers, driven people out of the country, and kept others looking over their shoulder for the rest of their lives. Because the bargain is, confess and there's a good chance you'll be released. Probably. Eventually. But the state could decide to bring a case against you afterward anyway. Or they could go after your friends and family. Or with all the personal details you've confessed along with political ones, the security services could blackmail you into working for them as a propagandist, an informant.
这些忏悔，尽管手段拙劣，却极具破坏性。它们结束了职业生涯，将人们驱逐出境，让其他人余生都要提心吊胆。因为交易是，忏悔了，很有可能你会被释放。大概。最终。但政府随时可以事后决定对你提起诉讼。或者他们可以针对你的朋友和家人。或者，随着你连同政治细节一起坦白的所有个人细节，安全部门可以敲诈你，让你为他们充当宣传者、告密者。
Meanwhile, many Iranians even today believe the confessions are genuine, or at least could be. For those who gets their news mostly from the state-run TV channels, the confessions seem as real as anything else on the news. Even Omid, before he was arrested, sometimes wondered if the stories he'd heard about torture and forced confessions were exaggerations, or even made up altogether. Like I said, very effective.
同时，许多伊朗人即使在今天也认为忏悔是真实的，或者至少可能是真实的。对于那些主要从国家电视台获取新闻的人来说，忏悔看起来和新闻里的其他内容一样真实。即使是奥米德，在入狱前，有时也会想，他听到的关于折磨和强迫忏悔的故事是否夸张了，甚至根本就是编造的。如我所说，非常有效。
I really understood at one point that it's not all about me. They are gathering information about the reformists. I mean for example, they gave me names at one point. And I said, "I have never seen these people. I know these people. I have never seen these people. And I cannot say that I have met them, or they have directed me, or they have guided me." And they told me that, "It's OK. When you confess, and when you use their names in your confession, it would be so alarming for them."
我有一次真正明白，这不仅仅是关于我。他们正在收集改革派的信息。例如，他们给了我名字。我说：“我从来没见过这些人。我知道这些人。但我从没见过他们。我不能说我见过他们，或者他们指导了我。”他们告诉我：“没关系。当你忏悔时，当你把他们的名字写进忏悔录时，这对他们来说将非常警示。”
So they wanted to intimidate those people, those reformists as well. They didn't care that I didn't meet any of those people. So the people who are in prison now, ranking reformists, they had been after them for five, six years. They just didn't decide to arrest them in the hours after the election. They had been planning for this for years.
所以他们也想恐吓那些人，那些改革派。他们不在乎我是否见过那些人。所以那些现在入狱的人，那些高级改革派，他们已经追踪他们五六年了。他们不是在选举后几个小时内才决定逮捕他们的。他们已经为此计划了多年。
Omid wrote six drafts for his interrogator, by his own estimate. And out of that they shaped a 5,000 word version, and a shorter 2,000 word op-ed style version. Excerpts were printed in several newspapers. And then he had to confess on TV.
据奥米德估计，他为审讯者写了六份草稿。在此基础上，他们塑造了一个5000字的版本，和一个较短的2000字评论风格版本。节选被印在几份报纸上。然后他不得不上电视忏悔。
And they told me, my interrogator said, "This is the last part of the game. You should be on TV, and it's over. Don't screw us."
他们告诉我，我的审讯者说：“这是游戏的最后一部分。你应该上电视，一切就结束了。别耍我们。”
Some TV confessions in Iran are the stark, looking-straight-at-the-camera confession you're probably imagining. But with other people-- journalists, or politicians, or big activists-- often it's staged as an informal interview in a room set up with chairs, a table, maybe some flowers, as though they're sitting down for a chat with Matt Lauer.
伊朗的一些电视忏悔是你可能想象的那种冷酷地直视镜头的忏悔。但对其他人——记者、政治家或大活动家——通常会被安排成一种非正式的采访，房间里布置了椅子、桌子，也许还有些花，就好像他们坐下来和马特·劳尔聊天一样。
It was a beautiful room, decorated beautifully with curtains, flowers, chairs, orange juice. But the thing was, I wanted to make it more unprofessional. So they had to cut all the time, say, no, cut, again. Omid, what are you doing? A few times I cried, and it was unintentional and also intentional, both. I didn't want to make it very easy for them.
那是一个美丽的房间，用窗帘、花、椅子装饰得很漂亮，还有橘子汁。但问题是，我想让它变得更不专业。所以他们必须一直喊停，说：“不，停，重来。奥米德，你在做什么？”我有几次哭了，那既是无意的也是有意的。我不想让他们觉得太容易了。
And was your chief interrogator there, behind the camera, saying you did it wrong, do it again?
你的首席审讯者在镜头后面说你做错了，重来一遍吗？
Yes. He was there, and he asked me to stop and I had to start again. So it took four hours to finish half an hour confession.
是的。他在那里，他让我停下来，我必须重来。所以花了四个小时完成了一个半小时的忏悔。
After Omid was released in December of 2004, he leaked to Human Rights Watch that he and about 19 others who had been arrested around the same time had been coerced into confessing. And the shocking thing was, many top government officials, when they heard what had happened to Omid and the others, were shocked-- officials like the president, moderate reformist Mohammad Hatami, and his ministers. It caused an uproar. And eventually, Omid and another young journalist met with the head of the judiciary, the Grand Ayatollah Shahroudi. He's still the head of the judiciary today. He's the Iranian equivalent of the attorney general.
2004年12月奥米德被释放后，他向人权观察组织泄露说，他和当时同时被捕的约19人是被强迫忏悔的。令人震惊的是，许多高层政府官员在听到奥米德和其他人的遭遇时，感到震惊——像总统、温和派改革派穆罕默德·哈塔米和他的部长们。这引起了轩然大波。最终，奥米德和另一位年轻记者会见了司法部长、大阿亚图拉沙鲁迪。他今天仍然是司法部长。他相当于伊朗的总检察长。
And Omid learned that the security forces' standard procedure with the confessions was to make copies and send them along to government officials top ayatollahs as proof that there were Iranian citizens bent on undermining and plotting against the state. And because the interrogators took so much care to make the confessions look unforced-- with the flowers in the vase, and the chatty interviewer, the confessing person not looking beat up or emaciated-- apparently, the videos were pretty convincing.
奥米德得知，安全部队处理忏悔的标准程序是复印一份，发给高级阿亚图拉等政府官员，作为证明有伊朗公民意图破坏和密谋反对国家的证据。而且因为审讯者非常小心地让忏悔看起来不像是强迫的——花瓶里的花，健谈的采访者，忏悔者看起来没有被打得鼻青脸肿或憔悴——显然，视频相当有说服力。
When Omid and the other journalist told the head of the judiciary everything that had led up to their confessions, it was clear to Omid that he was hearing these things for the first time.
当奥米德和其他记者告诉司法部长导致他们忏悔的一切时，奥米德很清楚他是第一次听到这些事。
I really trusted this guy. I felt that he was very honest. He had a very honest reaction. I could see in his face he was so angry. And he was saying all the time, "Allahu akbar." People use it when they do not believe something, or something is very stunning for them.
我真的很信任这个人。我觉得他非常诚实。他有非常诚实的反应。我能从他的脸上看到他非常生气。他一直说：“真主至大。”人们在不相信某事或某事让他们感到震惊时会用这句话。
But for all the shock and outrage, and the promises to look into what had happened and take action, nothing changed. Not because the head of the judiciary or anyone else was insincere, Omid thinks. They just weren't, and possibly aren't, strong enough to fight what was happening.
但尽管感到震惊和愤怒，尽管承诺调查发生了什么并采取行动，什么都没有改变。奥米德认为，不是因为司法部长或其他任何人不真诚。他们只是，甚至可能现在也不是，强到足以对抗正在发生的一切。
Many people are not happy, even in the conservative camp, even among Ahmadinejad supporters. They are really mad at what is going on. In my case, I remember that many people in the judiciary and in the government, conservatives that I had a chance to talk to them, they told me that they are so stunned at how these guys are brutal, and why they are doing this, and how they are not responsible.
许多人不满，即使在保守派阵营，即使在艾哈迈迪内贾德的支持者中。他们对发生的事情非常生气。就我的情况而言，我记得司法部和政府中的许多人，我有机会与他们交谈的保守派，他们告诉我，他们对这些人是多么残暴，为什么他们这么做，以及他们是如何不负责任感到震惊。
The lieutenant commander of Iran's Basij militia was quoted saying, "There are now so many confessions obtained from rioters that even if all the media mobilize for a long time to broadcast them, they still couldn't get all the information out to the people."
伊朗巴斯基民兵副指挥官被引述说：“现在从暴徒那里获得的忏悔太多了，即使所有媒体动员很长一段时间来播放它们，他们仍然无法将所有信息传达给民众。”
A few days before that story came out, one of the most senior ayatollahs in Iran, the Grand Ayatollah Montazeri, said in a translation on the Middle East Media Research Institute website, "The proud people of Iran know very well exactly how authentic the detainees' confessions are. They're like confessions obtained by fascist and communist regimes. The nation knows that the false confessions and televised interviews were obtained from its imprisoned sons with threats and torture, and that their aim is to cover up the oppression and injustice, and to present a distorted image of the people's peaceful and legal protest."
在那篇报道出来前几天，伊朗最资深的阿亚图拉之一，大阿亚图拉蒙塔泽里在中东媒体研究所网站上的一份翻译中说：“骄傲的伊朗人民非常清楚被拘留者的忏悔有多真实。它们就像法西斯和共产主义政权获得的忏悔。国家知道虚假的忏悔和电视采访是从其被囚禁的儿子那里通过威胁和折磨获得的，目的是掩盖压迫和不公正，并呈现人民和平合法抗议的歪曲形象。”
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show. Since that story first aired in 2009, Maziar Bahari, the writer for Newsweek whose confession that Nancy read, has been released.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制作人之一。自该故事于2009年首次播出以来，《新闻周刊》的撰稿人马齐亚尔·巴哈里，即南希读其忏悔录的那个人，已经被释放。
Act Four, May Be Hazardous to Children.
第四幕，对儿童可能有危险。
Well, we close today's show with a bit of fine print that codified and made irrevocable some other, bigger changes in the life of Susan Burton and her family.
嗯，我们今天以一段细则结束，这些细则编纂并使苏珊·伯顿及其家庭生活中的其他重大变化变得不可撤销。
When I was 13, my parents got divorced, and my mother and my sister and I moved from Michigan to Colorado. Like the pioneers, we settled in Indian territory, on a new street in a subdivision called Arapaho Ridge. Our house was the color of sand. It had vaulted ceilings, a sunken family room, and the thing we found most offensive, a wet bar. The wet bar, with its ugly brass fittings and diamond-paned glass, seemed to symbolize all that was wrong with our newly constructed lives. We were no longer the perfect family of four, worthy of a tasteful colonial. We were two latchkey kids and a single parent, and we'd been relocated to a tract house.
我13岁时，父母离婚了，母亲、妹妹和我从密歇根搬到了科罗拉多。像拓荒者一样，我们在印第安领地定居，在一条叫“阿拉帕霍岭”的小区的新街上。我们的房子是沙色的。有拱形天花板，下沉式家庭休息室，还有我们最反感的东西——湿吧台。那个带丑陋黄铜配件和钻石格玻璃的湿吧台，似乎象征着我们刚刚建立的生活中所有错误的地方。我们不再是完美的四口之家，配得上体面的殖民风格住宅。我们成了两个挂钥匙儿童和单亲，被安置在这一排房子里。
My mother displaced her anger about this onto the wet bar by refusing to use it for its intended function. The wet bar became our junk drawer. Instead of alcohol, she kept files in there, checkbook registers, coffee maker instructions, and my report cards, which, since moving to Colorado, had begun to show lower grades than I'd ever gotten.
母亲将对此的愤怒转移到了湿吧台上，拒绝按其预期功能使用它。湿吧台成了我们的杂物柜。她没在里面放酒精，而是放了文件，支票簿存根，咖啡机说明书，还有我的成绩单，自从搬到科罗拉多，那上面的成绩开始显示出我从未得到过的低分。
One day, I was looking for my standardized test scores. There was no reason except that it was clear to me I was becoming stupid, and I liked to be reminded that I'd once been smart. But instead, I found something unexpected, a big, green, hanging folder filled with documents labeled, "Divorce."
有一天，我找我的标准化考试分数。没别的理由，只是清楚地意识到我正在变蠢，而我喜欢提醒自己曾经很聪明。但相反，我发现了意想不到的东西，一个大的、绿色的、挂着的文件夹，装满了贴着“离婚”标签的文件。
There was a moment of deciding whether or not to open it. Then, cautiously, as if I might set off an alarm, I cracked the folder and began to read my parents' divorce agreement.
有一瞬间我决定是否打开它。然后，小心翼翼地，仿佛我会触发警报一样，我撬开了文件夹，开始阅读父母的离婚协议。
There was nothing dramatic-- no secret half siblings, not even a custody battle. To anyone else, the agreement would have read like what it was, a standard legal document. But my parents' divorce was the biggest thing in my life. I dwelled on it to the point of obsession, to the point of melodrama. As far as I was concerned, it was the most important fact about me.
没有什么戏剧性的东西——没有秘密的同父异母兄弟姐妹，甚至没有监护权争夺战。对别人来说，协议读起来就像它本来那样，一份标准的法律文件。但我父母的离婚是我生活中最大的事。我沉迷其中，到了痴迷和情节剧的程度。就我而言，这是关于我最重要的事实。
Discovering the agreement was like finding that a new story had somehow been bound into a book I'd already read a thousand times. And like a favorite story, the agreement became something I returned to a couple of times a year all throughout my teens.
发现协议就像发现一个新故事被装订进了我已经读过一千遍的书里。就像一个最爱的故事一样，协议成了我在青少年时期每年都要回去读几遍的东西。
Their names were on the cover page, my mother, the plaintiff, versus my father, the defendant. There was the horrible wrongness of that V that divided them. My mother was represented by a lawyer named Bruce Barnhardt. To him these agreements were probably just divorce Mad Libs. He'd sit at his big desk, with my mother across from him and fill in blanks. Debts-- $2,400, Cascade Country Club. Vehicles-- 1986 Volkswagen Jetta. Bank accounts-- Merrill Lynch.
封面上有他们的名字，母亲，原告，对比父亲，被告。那个分割他们的“V”字有种可怕的错误感。母亲的律师叫布鲁斯·巴恩哈特。对他来说，这些协议可能只是填空题。他坐在大办公桌前，母亲坐在对面，填着空白。债务——2400美元，卡斯卡德乡村俱乐部。车辆——1986年大众捷达。银行账户——美林证券。
But when I read the agreement, it didn't seem formulaic. These details were precious to me, and I was grateful they'd been so painstakingly recorded. It made me feel important that somebody took an interest, set down our story like that, even if the writer was just a lawyer in Grand Rapids, Michigan, who'd been paid to do it.
但当我读协议时，它看起来并不刻板。这些细节对我来说很珍贵，我很感激它们被如此费心地记录下来。有人对此感兴趣，把我们的故事这样写下来，即使写作者只是大急流城的一位律师，拿钱办事，也让我感到重要。
Sometimes I would copy stuff down from the agreement, as if the information contained in it could get lost just as easily as our family. On one page, I found the phone number of a house in which I'd briefly lived with my father when my parents first got separated. My father always had good phone numbers. He got them by telling the operator he had a retarded child who needed something easy to memorize. Not easy enough, apparently. I had forgotten this one. I copied the number down on a little Post-It note I saved for years, as if someday they might introduce a calling plan for dialing the past.
有时我会从协议中抄下东西，仿佛其中包含的信息像我们的家庭一样容易丢失。在某一页，我发现了我父母刚分开时我曾短暂随父亲居住的一所房子的电话号码。父亲总有很好的电话号码。他告诉接线员他有一个需要容易记忆号码的残疾孩子，从而得到这些号码。显然还不够容易。我已经忘了这个。我把它抄在一张保存了多年的小贴纸上，仿佛有一天他们会推出拨打过去的呼叫计划。
My parents had joint legal custody, but my mother had physical custody. This was divorced kid rank and serial number, and I was glad to know the exact terms. Child support would be deducted from my father's paychecks and sent directly to my mother through a program called Friend of the Court. For a second, I wondered if they were saying my father was a guy who couldn't be trusted to send the money himself. I knew it wasn't true, but it had never occurred to me before.
父母拥有共同法定监护权，但母亲拥有实际监护权。这是离异孩子阶级和编号，我很高兴知道确切的条款。抚养费将从父亲的工资支票中扣除，并通过一个叫“法院之友”的程序直接发送给母亲。有一秒钟，我想是否因为父亲是个不能被信任自己寄钱的人。我知道那不是真的，但我以前从未想到过。
Going through the folder always brought a rush of different feelings. There's the fear I'd be caught, or that I'd find something disturbing, that my parents had done bad things or were bad people. But even the smallest thing could move me, something as simple as seeing my parents' initials together on the bottom right-hand corner of each page of a legal document.
翻阅文件夹总是带来一阵不同的感受。害怕被抓住，或者发现令人不安的东西，比如父母做过坏事或人品不好。但即使是最微小的事情也会打动我，就像在法律文件的每一页右下角看到父母的首字母组合在一起那样简单。
One afternoon, I found a document that stopped me cold. The hearing that was to set my parents' divorce in motion was only days away. But in this note, Mr. Barnhardt had written, "Dear Nancy, this will confirm our telephone conference. I have adjourned the hearing date from January 30, 1987, to February 27, 1987. I wish you well in your efforts to resolve your marital difficulties."
一天下午，我发现了一份让我停下来的文件。那份启动父母离婚程序的听证会只有几天之遥。但在那张纸条里，巴恩哈特先生写道：“亲爱的南希，这将确认我们的电话会议。我已将听证日期从1987年1月30日延期至1987年2月27日。祝愿你在解决婚姻困难的努力中一切顺利。”
I sat before the wet bar for a beat. I was a scholar of my parents' divorce who'd just found the primary document of my dreams. Here was the suggestion that my parents had tried to stay together. I ached that they hadn't been able to reconcile.
我坐在湿吧台前坐了一会儿。我是父母离婚的学者，刚刚找到了梦想中的原始文献。这里暗示着父母曾试图留在一起。他们没能复合让我心痛。
It's been almost 20 years since I've lived in that house, and I hadn't looked at the agreement since, until recently. I asked my mother for the folder, and after she gave it to me, it took me a couple of days to open it. I was worried that the agreement wouldn't give me the same feeling. Maybe the story of my family's disintegration had lost its hold over me. It was possible that, like the music of Bon Jovi, I'd be mystified by its former appeal.
我离开那栋房子已经快20年了，直到最近我才重看协议。我向母亲要了文件夹，她给我后，我过了几天才打开。我担心协议不会给我同样的感受。也许我家庭解体的故事已经失去了对我的束缚。就像邦乔维的音乐一样，我可能会对它曾经的吸引力感到困惑。
But the agreement held up better than I'd expected. I'd forgotten that a divorce agreement is like a murder mystery, where the murder happens on the first page. The opening language is brutal. "There has been a breakdown in the marriage relationship to the extent that the objects of matrimony have been destroyed, and there remains no reasonable likelihood that the marriage can be preserved. Now, therefore, it is ordered and adjudged that this marriage is hereby dissolved."
但协议的表现比我预期的要好。我忘了离婚协议就像谋杀谜案，谋杀发生在第一页。开篇的语言是残酷的。“婚姻关系已破裂，以至于婚姻的目的已不复存在，且婚姻已无保留的合理可能性。现因此，命令并裁定此婚姻特此解散。”
I felt the same way reading these words at my desk as an adult as I had on the floor at 14. Back then, these words knocked the wind out of me. To me this wasn't legalese. I wasn't old enough ever to have signed a contract for a rental or to have read the terms and conditions of a credit card agreement. To me this was the language of proclamations and founding documents. It was commensurate with my experience of my parents' divorce as an event that had changed the world. The weight I felt inside was matched by the weight of these words. At the end of those summer afternoons, I'd return the divorce agreement to the wet bar as reverently as if I were replacing the Constitution in its marble shrine.
作为一个成年人，我在桌前读这些话的感受和14岁时在地板上读时是一样的。那时候，这些话让我喘不过气来。对我来说，这不是法律术语。我还不够大，没签过租赁合同，也没读过信用卡协议的条款和条件。对我来说，这是宣言和创始文件的语言。它与我作为改变世界事件的父母离婚的经历相称。我内心感受到的重量与这些文字的重量相匹配。那些夏日午后的最后，我会像把宪法放回大理石神龛一样虔诚地把离婚协议放回湿吧台。
Susan Burton lives in New York.
苏珊·伯顿住在纽约。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who follows me around the office trying to get me to say the letter L, which he knows I cannot say. He especially loves it when I say the name Lillian Hellman.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。节目的WBEZ管理监督是我们老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他一直跟在我身后试图让我说出字母L，他知道我发不出这个音。他尤其喜欢我念莉莲·海尔曼的名字。
Go on. Say it. Say it. Say it.
说吧。说出来。说出来。说出来。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。